[Music]
hello everyone I wanted to first start
with a quick show of hands how many
people here have experimented with
computer vision wow it's like almost
half of the room how many people here
have effectively deployed computer
vision models in production a
significantly smaller number so
hopefully by the end of my talk you're
gonna be as excited as I am so we plot
these models and production to solve
actual business problems my name is
Francisco da and I'm the product lead
for auto ml and the computer vision
teams in this talk we will discuss
Google's computer vision offerings I'll
first start by providing a quick
introduction into our building blocks
and then I turn it over three of our
distinguished customers and partners to
talk more about how they are using their
technology our technology I wanted to
first start by sharing the mission of
our team our job is to enable developers
and partners to build the next
generation computer vision autonomy
solutions whether you're an energy
company secret to attack rust or denting
in a wind turbine or whether you're an
automaker seeking to integrate driver
assistance into your vehicles or a
financial institution seeking to extract
text from scanned documents we want to
provide you with a rich and high-quality
set of building blocks for you to
implement in assemble this autonomy
solutions and the way we do that is by
packaging and putting at your
fingerprints
Google's state-of-the-art machine
learning acceleration hardware like
cloud and HTTP use and more than a
decade in state-of-the-art computer
vision and machine perception research
so specifically our team is part of the
cloud a family of products and we focus
on three main areas
the first one vision API and the second
one video intelligence API help you
understand your images and abuse
respectively
using the power of googled priori models
and the third one auto ml is a suite of
products that help you build high
quality machinery models with no
machinery expertise required let's first
start with a vision API the vision API
helps you understand your images using
Google pre-trained models you can use
this API to extract value from your
images extract content and then
integrate this content into your
applications vision API has a rich set
of features for you to understand your
images ranging from content annotation
OCR all the way to content moderation
but since the last recipe next I'm
exciting to introduce four key new
capabilities the first 100 in OCR helps
you extract handwritten text from your
documents the second one object
localizer
help you extract not only the presence
but the actual coordinates of objects in
your images and the third one web
detection helps you extract entities and
similar images from the web leveraging
the power of google search and the
fourth one product search helps
retailers integrate visual search into
their mobile and web applications in the
next few slides I'll provide three
example solutions that customers are
assembling with our technology in the
first one customers are combining the
power of vision API content annotation
features with pops of an app engine to
index their images a scale and be able
to query them using the rich metadata
via corporation as using this to target
their content and find the right media
assets for the next production or media
campaign financial institutions are
using this to find text in a large set
of scanned documents
and even retailers are using this to
find products simply using visual
features the second one customers are
combining the power of vision API or CR
in our natural language api's to be able
to classify and extract structure
information from their scanned documents
companies are using this to digitize
their content and enable new workflows
and business processes downstream and if
the last one retailers are using our API
to build visual search applications and
the way they are doing that is by first
detecting different types of products
like sneakers pants or a t-shirt using
our object localizer API and then
sending those crops to the Product
Search API to retrieve the exact SKU of
the product in a customer's catalog so
in a nutshell you can assemble all these
solutions using our vision API with no
machinery expertise required now
switching gears I wanted to talk about
the video intelligence API this API
helps you annotate and understand your
videos at scale in a short period of
time you can think of video intelligence
API as vision API but heavily optimized
for videos meaning we leverage temporal
component of videos but as vision API
being talents API has features for
content annotation like label detection
and content moderation like safe search
but it also has additional video
specific features like shot change
detection media and entertainment
companies are using this to tag that
vast databases of video footage
advertising companies are using this to
determine the right place in time were
to place contextual ads in the video
streams and
companies are also using this to extract
rich metadata from their videos to
enhance the quality of the
recommendation engines so independent of
the uses of our customers we're very
excited about what they are doing with
our technology but this is just the
beginning in the next few weeks
we'll be introducing key new
capabilities that are going to enhance
our video intelligence capabilities even
further so please stay tuned
now if the video intelligence API or the
vision API do not meet your needs
because your data belongs to a specific
domain or because you want us to add
additional support for your own concepts
we introduce Auto ml Auto ml is the
suite of products that helps you build
high quality machinery models for your
own data and for your own use case with
no machinery expertise required we all
know machine learning is hard whenever
you're confronted with a machine
learning challenge you have to determine
what is the right set of data
pre-processing techniques to use which
models you use if you're using deep
learning you need to determine which
architecture to use or which set of
hybrid parameters to pick and after you
don't train your model you need to
determine what is the right serving
infrastructure to serve these models at
scale and meeting whatever latency
requirements you may have this entire
process is very time-consuming requires
a lot of money because training a lot of
these models takes a lot of
computational resources and at the same
times require significant machine
learning expertise so that's the reason
why we introduce Auto ml to help you
automate the most complex hardest steps
in building a machine on your model and
this way you can focus on high-value
activities like collecting the right
data and defining the right set of
business objectives for your problem and
all of this without having to compromise
on machine learning quality so in a
nutshell Auto ml helps you build high
quality machinery models for your own
data and after your trainer model
with the ploidies model on an API easy
to use that you can use to run
predictions from the rest of your data
set yesterday faith introduced two new
auto ml products Auto ml natural
language and other ml translate but the
most relevant or e ml for this
particular session is Auto ml vision
that helps to build high quality image
classification models so for example
let's imagine that you're a retailer
trying to classify different types of
products into your own set of categories
all you have to do is probably as a
series of examples of handbags shoes and
hats and Auto ml does a magic behind the
scenes to produce a model that then you
can later use to tag the rest of your
product catalog now how does Auto ml
work behind the scenes behind the scenes
Auto ml uses AI to build AI every time
you pass your data to auto ml an AI
agent builds a high quality deep
learning model with optimal architecture
and set of hyper parameters to solve
your particular business need now to
test this technology we'll run our ml an
image net arguably the most popular and
heavily studied data scientist data set
an auto ml managed to produce new state
of there are results on this data set
and what's even more remarkable is the
fact that because these models are
produced by AI it can optimally trade
off the model size and the accuracy of
this model something that's crucial to
deploy these models on the edge so in a
nutshell Auto ml is the product for
citizen data scientist developers to
build high quality models and with a
great user experience and to illustrate
the point about the user experience I
wanted to quickly show you guys a demo
of auto ml let's imagine that we are all
meteorologists trying to classify
forests of the sky into different types
of clouds which I recently learned is
actually a good predictor of future
weather events
so if I confronted with this problem all
I would have to do is collect a few
example images for each one of these
different types of clouds and then open
Auto ml open Auto ml and click on a new
dataset let's say I want to create
clouds 3 and here I'm offered two
different options to upload my data I
can either upload them from my local
hard drive in a sip file or by putting
out a Google Cloud Storage packet but
since I have already uploaded a clouds
data set I'm going to go back to the
data set section and pick clouds - that
has around 1,800 images somebody in our
team actually attack like these photos
and here you can see all the different
steps required to build a model like
ranging from images all the way to
prediction and the first part images as
a Google photos like UI for you to
manage your images here you can curate
your labels and your even the image
labels and we show you your label
distribution so you can determine how to
properly balance your data set so after
you're done curating your your training
data set you can move to the next step
train and here we show all the different
models that you have already trained
with a corresponding precision and
recall values if you want to train a new
model all you have to do is click train
your model and that's it now if I want
to learn more about the performance of
one particular model all I have to do is
click on C evaluation here we show more
advanced metrics like the precision and
recall graphs PR and PR curves and at
the same time you can tweak the score
threshold for you to determine the ideal
trade-off between precision and recall
or your particular business use case and
scrolling down you can see the confusion
matrix that shows the labels that the
model is confusing so for instance you
can see that the model is confusing all
the cumulus labels with serious labels
around 23.8% of the time so if you click
on that cell will show you example
images that the model is is confusing so
you can
a more guided or educated guess about
which additional images to upload to
improve the quality model at the
decision boundaries so after you're done
curating your data set and you have
built a model that you're happy with you
can go to the predictive and here we
show different options how to query your
model with a simple REST API script or a
Python script but if you know rush you
you can simply upload an image from your
hard drive here I'm going to test
uploading an image and pull up you can
see that the model accurately predicted
this is a cumulus label now switching
back to the slides
so to wrap up my session I wanted to
announce that since we launched our ml
we've had more than 18,000 signups so
extremely humbled by our attraction our
customers use cases spam multiple
verticals ranging from medical imaging
to retailers tagging product images all
the way to waste management corporations
using auto ml to sort out different
types of trash like landfill compost or
recycling but independent of the use
cases independence of all the verticals
and the size of our customers were
extremely happy about what they are
doing with our technology and I don't
note I wanted to introduce Eli Cohn
stage he's the head of data science at
literati
[Applause]
I'm Eli I'm the data scientist at little
Ari we are a platform that empowers
people in cleaning the planet each year
14 billion pounds of trash flow into our
oceans four trillion cigarettes are
thrown on the ground 11 billion is spent
in cleaning it up in US alone litter
destroys the environment kills wildlife
poisons our food system yet strangely
there's no data so we built an app using
our app each user can take a picture of
litter say a Starbucks or a Burger King
cup tag it and that then dispose of it
the data that we collect from each user
is their user name what they picked up a
geo tag tells us where and a timestamp
tells us when and in turn we're building
the global database for litter the first
of its kind and ultimately a little free
planet what we understand is the data we
collect and its integrity it's critical
the data we collect is used by cities
nonprofit organizations brands and
schools across the world for example in
San Francisco our data generates annual
tax revenue of four million dollars but
we understand the problem we are trying
to solve is complex so we partnered up
with Google's Auto ml team and what it
helps us do is makes the process make
the process as easy as possible for our
users so that they can pick up more
litter and our data smarter so what auto
ml does it takes the user images
and in the backend performs image
recognition bit this helps us in our
data integrity this is just a sample of
examples of user images that auto ml has
tagged in the backend with great results
hands down for us at literati Google's
Auto ml has proved to be powerful
easy to use with a robust process flow
moving forward we want to take Auto ml
from the backend and put it in use each
user app to improve the user tagging so
user will still take a picture our 2 ml
will tag it in their app and then our
user will help us improve our little
database by going in and adding
additional tags say a local brand of
beer or coca-cola or Cola or candy and
guess what our literati story is
spreading we have some amazing partners
with United Nations being the most
recent and we're just getting started
thank you so much for letting me share
[Applause]
it's a lot alike so now I wanted to
introduce you to Sencha the last
scientists are open door to talk about
their experience using our ml thanks
Francisco so guys I'm Zane Shaw from the
data science team at open door and you
may be wondering what is open door well
our mission is to empower everyone with
the freedom to move what that means is
instead of doing a bunch of repairs
repairs on your home working with an
agent to list your home having random
people show up at odd hours of the day
instead you just go to our website tell
us a bit about your home and we figure
out from our data what we think it'll
what we think it'll be able to solve for
and we make an offer to buy your house
for that amount an instant cash offer if
you like our offer you just sell it to
us and relax you don't have to do much
at all you can just move on with your
life
now this may sound like a crazy pipe
dream but we've actually made a lot of
progress so far people love what we're
doing this time last year we were in
three cities now we're in ten we've
acquired 800,000 houses and put them on
the market we now spend about a billion
dollars a year purchasing homes and all
these numbers are growing and we're
expanding very quickly now what does
that experience look like well you
basically just go to our website you
tell us where you live and from there we
use our data to make more informed
decisions I can show you a bit of what
it looks like go to our website
tell us where you live like I said and
through our process you basically just
give us some information that we might
not automatically have and you tell us
like what's going on inside your home
from this we can dynamically calculate
how much we think we're going to be able
to sell the home for and if you like
what we offer you can basically just
sell your home to us for that amount in
relax you can also investigate what our
prediction was and how we came to that
amount and it's a it's a very easy
experience there now from the data
science team at open door the sorts of
problems that I deal with are pretty
crucial to the business problems we deal
with are like accurately valuing homes
totally sight unseen you just go to our
website and tell us a bit and we have to
figure out actually what it's going to
sell for this is important for us to
actually do this at scale we need to
predict how long it'll take to sell and
we need to analyze market dynamics to
correctly understand what's going on in
the market and optimally price the homes
now like I said one of our primary
challenges is valuing someone's home
totally sight unseen as you can see here
these two homes they might look very
similar on paper but in person it's
quite clear that the home on the left is
not very nice so how do we know this
well we can actually figure out from
photos for example how nice the home is
there there are a bunch of things that
are maybe not what drives the value of
the home but definitely are strong
indicators that we've isolated that are
mostly proxy features things like if you
have stainless steel appliances that's a
pretty good indicator if you have
granite countertops that's a pretty good
indicator brand-new cabinets
separate tub and shower in your bathroom
things like that now like you saw in the
flow we get some data from our sellers
they tell us exactly a lot of the
structured information like whether they
have granite countertops but for the
historical transactions that we train
our models on we don't get that at all
we get the square footage number of
bathrooms maybe how many stories the
home has and where it's located but none
of this information that we really need
so that's where computer vision comes in
from the historical transactions we
don't have the structured data but we do
have photos so we can look at the photos
of the home we can figure out whether
it's whether it has an upgraded kitchen
whether it has a nice bathroom and we
can use that to better inform our
decisions but the problem there is
that's actually pretty time-consuming
and difficult so that's me on the right
there in a past life I've spent weeks
poring over filter visualizations from
convolutional neural networks to
understand what was going on and
improved the performance but it's a lot
of work and sometimes it doesn't even
work super well and it takes away too
long
so that's where auto amel comes in
basically all we had to do in order to
test this use case is get a bunch of
labels in a spreadsheet upload them to
Google Cloud Auto ml and from there we
get a perfectly like very well accurate
model that predicts exactly what we want
in this case whether a kitchen has
stainless steel appliances or not with
basically zero work what's next for us
well we want to get more labels the more
we know about our home the better and so
that this means things like features
about the bathrooms living rooms
backyards and other image resources as
well Auto ml is very flexible and so we
can look at aerial imagery different
rooms even Street view images to
understand what a home looks like from
the outside thanks awesome Thank You
Jane and now we have Rob Munro at figure
CD our fee rate talked about our human
labeling partnership all right Thank You
Francisco so something that all of these
auto ml use cases have in common which
is different from a lot of the existing
off-the-shelf api's in DCP is that they
rely on human label data so it's humans
who are going in and saying this label
applies to this image and then that
powers that the machine learning to do
this at scale so figure 8 is a company
that provides software to label your
data from machine learning so we're the
most widely used software for GCP
customers today and was delightful to
find out as we're organizing this that
open door is actually one of our
customers so those images that you saw
in the the previous presentation are
ones that our workforce labeled for them
and you can find the juice case on our
website so if you if you need to have
humans label data for machine learning
there's a number of things that you need
to think carefully about first of all
how can you make this process as
efficient as possible so how can you
have a smart interface that allows
someone to create those right labels as
quickly as possible and remove a lot of
the redundancy secondly you need to
think about who is the right workforce
for this if you have a volume of labels
where you can't put your data scientists
on this manual task then you might want
to reach out and use crowdsource or
professional labels labels and and so we
manage marketplace so we're about a
hundred thousand people who regularly
annotate data for all kinds of different
information finally you want good
machine learning integration so you want
to be able to take your human label data
put it into your automobile models and
they're also quickly integrate iterate
as you need to add more data so one
particular use case I'm looking at which
I'll speak about here takes us from the
first presentation was which is about
computer vision across the entire world
the second presentation which was about
computer vision for your home I'm gonna
go inside your home specifically into
your closets and talking about your
shoes so who
here is familiar with WGSN it won't okay
look around the people with their hands
up next to you they are the best-dressed
people in this room so um I just have a
bunch of extra hands go up
so WGSN or a company that predicts
fashion trends one very important part
of making this forecast is to see what
is currently being sold across a very
large number of different retailers
websites and as you can imagine these
trends are much more fine-grain than is
just shoes versus sure it's missus
dresses it's about very specific types
and stylings within these different
pieces of clothing so you can see in
this example here this is something that
the human might look at okay is this a
shoe yes it is what kind of shoe is it
so is it is it a heel or is it a flat
shoe and so you can see that the
annotator here there are the human
creating this annotation they can see an
example of what a flat versus a heel is
where the text description of that
inline allowing them to quickly use
those instructions to make the right
decision
similarly here if they selected a boot
this is a categorical distinction
between a lace-up boot and a slip-on
boot so this kind of interface is one of
the ways in which you're able to get
high quality training data because you
know that even if it's not someone doing
the labeling that you're interacting
directly with you were able to provide
them with the the right instructions and
so once these data points have all been
labeled according to their categories
you can take this information
automatically put it into Auto ml and
have this process run at scale one of
the nice features of Auto ml is that it
will tell you the confidence of these
prediction and it has a really good
correlation between confidence and
accuracy as to what this means for
someone like WGSN or some with a similar
use case is that they can use auto ml to
automate everything that they know is
correct by machine learning and then for
those remaining items because I need to
get 100% accuracy they can put those
back to humans for review so minimizing
the human part and optimizing as much as
they can so that they can have these
accurate forecasts so this is what the
your platform looks like to do this I'm
looking to go into all the details here
just a couple of points as to in
addition to having configurable
interfaces that allows you to set these
instructions correctly there are a
number of quality controls so for
example you can set which workforces
work on this task so we work with a lot
of retail companies so eBay they saw
earlier is not about customer is also
someone that we do image labeling for
and so the same people who have learned
about different fashions through eBay
can also be working on your particular
task you can automatically give the task
to multiple people so you're getting a
certain level of agreement for items
that might be ambiguous and you can also
use that our patented system for
embedding test questions so if there are
some items which you already know the
labelled answers they can be hidden
along the way and thereby you're
evaluating the accuracy of every single
person that's working on this platform
and so will often have tens of thousands
of people working in parallel for a
single clients use case and it's this
kind of technology that enables you to
scale to that kind of work for us very
seamlessly the the final thing which is
very important is making this annotation
as accurate as possible and this is
somewhere where you can combine machine
learning and this is best demonstrated
as a video rather than rather than me
talking so you can see here machine
assisted video annotation of two methods
side by side the bottom being the one
that you can use in our platform so you
can imagine right if you have you know
30 frames a second times 10 seconds
that's 300 frames times 20 objects 6000
individual objects that you might want
to identify so what we have in our
system is a way that these objects are
automatically tracked between frames
still allowing that human annotator to
review every single one and only make
the update the correction or the
deletion when the machine learning has
gotten this wrong and so in this
particular use case you can see we're
about 25 to 30 times faster with no loss
of accuracy and we'll see this be up to
a hundred times faster for a lot of our
customers as to what that means is that
the human component of creating data
could be reduced to 1% or you could edit
eight a hundred times more data or apply
a hundred times more use cases for that
budget
and this could be either if you're used
in the workforce and now marketplace or
deficiency gains that you're getting if
you're bringing your own workforce to
this particular task so we're really
proud to announce today the figure-eight
and Google cloud partnership for Ottawa
bail so that anyone using auto ml can
take advantage of the figure-eight
annotation platform this is four
particular components to this
customizable annotation template so that
same interface that you saw for
classifying types of clothes can be used
for any kind of computer vision task and
you can use both our inbuilt workflows
and JavaScript to customize that as much
as you like to our use case assigned
consultants so if you new trying to get
quality training data from a distributed
human workforce our consultants can help
you with that
human labeling so like I said access to
the hundred thousand people in our
marketplace both crowd-sourced workers
and professionals that you can interact
with directly get paid by the hour and
quality control are the three different
quality control methods that I spoke
about today and so I'd love to hand this
back over to Francisco who can talk more
about this partnership thanks a lot Rob
and to wrap up I wanted to invite you to
learn more about our products at cloud
the google.com slash vision and cloud
the google.com slash video
- intelligence second in a topic that
requires a session on its own at Google
we are committed to the responsible use
of AI and that's the first step our team
put together a guide to help our AML
customers detect and potentially
mitigate the bias and the data sets and
models so if you want to learn more
about that guide you can go to cloud no
google.com slash inclusive ml it's
important to note that this is a live
document and we're really eager to hear
your feedback so so please
stay in touch and last but not least I
wanted to invite you to participate in a
limited time offer exclusive for the
members of this audience we are offering
two hours free of machine learning and
furnace consultation including free
Dowson annotations do you want to
participate in this offer you can go to
triple w dot figure dash eight.com slash
Auto ml and all you have to do is
provide your contact information say
that you came to this this session and
then provide a quick overview of your
use case and then somebody in our team
reach out to you shortly so with that
wanted to thank
[Applause]
[Music]